[Music]
hello guys so
today's lecture my name is darius
as probably you know today i'm going to
talk about
[Music]
about one opening which is
pretty rare uh rarely met on top level
still happens but it's kind of rare and
it's usually
chosen by uh by players with
to play with black pieces when they try
to avoid mainstream theory
after one d4 so uh
i've personally i think this opening
this
is pretty interesting and i myself
employed it in few games
especially lately and if
white doesn't know how to do the games
can
be pretty actually short as we will see
in the in one of the several examples
of one of the one one of examples so
um i've in general i think it's a pretty
interesting
opening and i want to share share with
you guys
what can happen there so let's get
started
uh d4 d6 so what's the idea
it's basically as for a starter i have
to say about this that
this the move d4 idea of d46 is
mostly used against players who play
only
one d4 and they do not play rather
one e4 and that's
kind of like the main premise i would
say because what was
what's going on because d4 basically the
4d6 allows
rather comfortable control over the
center of e4 right and this is sort of a
problem
for about this opening but is again it
is aimed at mostly against players who
don't who do not play e4 and of course
you play d1d4
uh d6 you have to be ready what to do
after e4 and
there are several possibilities around
the possibilities playing with simply g6
and either inviting xenia c4 g7
or go for sort of peer uh with
you know without knight f6 or at least
not have knight f6
so there's one possibility second
possibility is to play classical perk
which is basically the most
common approach here because
right now after g6
especially for against players who do
not play e4
or sorry wouldn't play e4 right now this
pawn c2 is kind of backward
and normally white players
would like to have it on c4 we've also
played d4 only
and here we enter pirk which is lots of
theory and maybe white is not ready for
this
and third part possibility is to play
after knight c3 move e5 which transfers
to philidor
uh which also is a possibility against
players who not necessarily play one
e4 not saying those openings are great
they equalize but they are possible and
sometimes when
whenever white is not ready for those
openings
uh meaning while they play only one d4
they don't play one e4
it could be a good try to basically use
the move order
to start with d4 d6 and that's the main
idea
um so d4 d6 so assuming we're playing
against a
player who plays only one d4 we sort of
can
say or assume that e4 is not going to
happen but there are several other
possibilities
and one possibility the most common okay
two most common they are equally common
is
once i mean two c4 and knight f3
so uh let's talk about at first uh
knight f3
so if knight f3 uh black can play knight
f6 and here we enter
star of kings indian style positions
however there
with the series with the series
distinction
uh comparing to let's say classical move
order which will be let's say the d4 and
f64 g6
the thing is that after right now c4 for
example
uh g6 knight c3 there's alternative of
playing with bishop f5
and the idea is to simply stop move e4
and this is quite a rare i mean actually
it's quite
this is quite a rare option here for uh
for black
is much less much less common than
classical kings indian however it is
playable and i saw many games of fabian
caruana
played playing this play in this line
i think twice he played against
varakopian and also
and many other grandmasters played it as
well i haven't
gotten to try this myself with black
pieces exactly this line
however i tried something similar so we
will talk about it later
so uh bishop f5 the idea is simply stop
e4
and classical kings ninja setup and if
white tries to
play e4 anyway somehow like by playing
with let's say knight
a35 or not h4 it denies sort of a little
bit
odd on those squares and maybe black can
sort of take advantage of that
so that's the kind of main idea so in
this position
there are several possibilities for why
i didn't cover all of them because
it's a quite a huge line the most
important i think to be familiar with
ideas or no exact lines
so um in this position
there are lots of possibilities one of
the main ones will be let's say queen b3
because bishop
escape move bishop moves from c8 makes
sense to attack the pawn b7
and right now i really like the approach
that was i saw in the game of alex
ibatov who played move b6 in this
position
and the idea of b6 is seemingly weakens
the
you know queen side and you know this
light squares are pretty kind of like
exposed but i don't see
exactly why the way to uh exploit that
for
for white for instance g3 makes sense to
right now develop this bishop on this to
the diagonal because
the both squares are weak so it makes
sense to bring this bishop there
um like this so black plays knight c6
right now
bishop g2 and simply bishop g7 and
actually there is no way to
make kind of like take advantage of this
lose knight on c6 because i h4
always first of all knight takes d4 but
also
i can always if i want to be super
excited play bishop december 94 of
course is much stronger
so in a game happened between mikhail
srilli and alexandria
was queen a4 bishop d7 queen d1
castle castle and here we get to play e5
so here is another benefit let's say of
playing let's say design bishop f5
sometimes we may transfer to lines with
kings indians sort of with g3 and
not everyone plays the king's indians
with g3 sometimes they
people play and use amish sometimes they
play maybe other bach maybe a classical
main line with e4 knight of three bishop
v2 maybe h3
here we got to for instance uh with the
line with g3 which is
maybe not in the repertoire so therefore
by using this move order of d6
we can sort of trick our opponent to
playing positions which are still
familiar to us but not necessarily for
our opponent
so that's the kind of main idea right
now uh
d5 it happened in this game and right
now alex
alex apollo played 97 alternative will
be 95 both moves are playable
idea of knight a5 could be knight b7
then a5 knight c5
also could be an idea to play right now
a6 and b5 and prove that
they would design it from a5 attack this
pawn on c4
however 97 is very logical too because
after
e4 uh even though alex didn't play it he
played quick c8 but i think uh
he 98 here of idea of h6 and f5 is
pretty standard
uh plan for black and actually move b6
it's rather helpful
for black because it stops any sort of
like c5
uh ideas and so on stabilizes the queen
side
for sure so i think positions pretty
much unbalance their opinions on the
board
and considering you know that
our opponent may not be ready for let's
say
this type of position we we might have
as black
good chances to you know
win the game i'm gonna create some
chances for ourselves in the in the
future stages
because we simply would be you know
better over the the start right
so yeah this would be this for queen b3
for instance is alternative but i don't
i i don't like it as much
another idea is let's say for for for
why to
would be to challenge the bishop on the
five immediately because if white
doesn't change the bishop in any way we
can just play bishop g7
short castle and you know white don't
not play e4
with this certain achievement by by
black to
not allow such simple control over
to control over the center of e4 so
knight h4
and knight g5 are are alternatives that
are considered as
sort of the most uh challenging but
okay let's talk about knight g5 if it's
already on the board now g5 bishop d7
because right now we have to acknowledge
that we can't stop e4 but bishop d7 so
we have to play bishop d7 sooner or
later we have to
retreat with this bishop and if after e4
we can play right now e5
and the hero is one of the benefits why
we played this idea of bishop f5
because knight on g5 right now is not
ideally placed probably has to go back
at some point to f3 but if we go neither
free back
this kind of like this is a tempe so
it's not optimal as well
and if d5 trying to keep this knight on
g5 this
on the other hand it closes the center
too early and we can play bishop g7
let's say a5
we don't have we do not have to castle
yet there are certain positions where
black can postpone castling and maybe
play quickly for f5
and you know we can just delay it for
later and we can see what white is doing
meantime
knight a6 95 could be definitely one of
the ideas right now for black
so um ionize also f4 which is
a move to try which tries to stop e5 but
it also
leads to very unclear and unbalanced
positions because bishop g7 bishop
i mean e4 and now e5 as well happens
after f takes e5 details e5
it seems like white can just win a pawn
after dxe5 but indeed
in reality it doesn't bleed to anything
special uh
so i think that d5 would be a better try
uh just quickly of what happens after
the takes d5 there was game uh
kramnik uh versus maximum shallow graph
and there happened on g4 e6 bishop e6
queen takes d8 king takes d8
it's true our king on the 8 is you know
kind of castle anymore but on the other
hand in exchange we got a
perfect square for our knight on e5
and here definitely black is not worse
i would say because of such powerful
knight on e5
so therefore d5
i produce a bird try but again knight a6
and here we get like you know some
uh sorry not a bishop difficult
bishop b2 h6 let's say knight f3 simply
not c5 queen c2 queen e7
we got some you know unbalanced position
where
both sides have its own chances pretty
much like uh
it's totally it's not like typical
kingdom right now f and d pawns are
traded
maybe as black we can play a a5 i mean
if i was definitely one of the moves
and maybe then we can try to bring our
knight to d6 by let's say playing short
castle
while the idea would be let's say an
idea knight d6 and then try to play for
f5
it could be one of the ideas of course
by us
playing first a5 because we need to
control before so
uh this could be a possibility so but
the question is what happened what
happens after before immediately because
seems like we are just losing a piece or
if we go with 96 our knight is very
passive there
so here is the thing here we go knight
takes e4 there are such ideas
as well and f5 we simply go for
immediate counter play
and after queen h4 we can play e4 and we
are getting back the piece
and we certainly do not have any
problems as i say rupee one we can just
take back the pieces and game is
not any better at all uh for for white i
think position just around equal
just to show it root b1 let's say take
stakes
we can play as black maybe i mean king
f7 looks good
rook e8 looks good but let's say this is
looking very natural as well
so i think position just you know pretty
good for black
so
this is all such ideas are possible uh
and
it is not entirely easy for white to
proof like being serious advantage one
of the best strikes i think is would be
also knight h4
and after bishop d7 then e4 uh
but again i another h4 is also not a not
a great piece we can play either for e5
or maybe for bishop g7
and then e5 both approaches are pretty
valid after this this knight c6 i saw
some games of
i think uh i think it was fabiano carmen
who played 96 here d597
and again we got sort of king's indian
style position but we have the bishop on
d7 which is
already there uh which in many lines can
be simply helpful
so we got sort of kingdom of temp tempe
tempera not some
it may maybe it's not necessary but
sometimes
like maybe it's not relevant but maybe
sometimes in in particular in some
particular
it could be really useful so uh it's not
entirely
you know that you know white has nice
center and that's you know it's all
i think great there are some chances for
black for sure other possibilities to
also play bishop g7
which is this kind of similar positions
with e5
that knight from h4 has to go back to f3
at some point
and this again resides some kings indian
with tempe
up for black essentially so it can't be
bad
uh so yeah this would be basically
covered
this would cover pretty much like one of
them say main or like you know one of
the
many let's say logical let's say human
uh
level let's say approaches here by why
there are also others is h3 which is
very interesting and
challenging there is uh e3 uh there is
d5
what varakum played i remember bishop g5
also is interesting
uh g3 transferring to the kings india
with g3 also is possible so
covering all of that would take really
like i could
just spend on this position and every
all my time but like you know i want to
cover
all one d4 d6 so i think
this gives already an a good picture
what to do expect here as black
and we can move on to the next variation
which i prepared which is
uh let's say if white plays with g3 and
we could
there's different move orders we could y
could start with c4 g6 and c3 bishop f5
uh g3 or like this g3 immediately g6
bishop g7
uh and the short castle shore castle c4
c6
and yeah i mean by the way this position
in this position black has
number of possibilities is this
essentially kings and with g3 right
but following the same suit as earlier
we should
i would suggest playing c6 and c3 bishop
f5
it is a pretty interesting line
and i i think that
objectively watch should be somewhat
better here but it's never easy to prove
it
it's never easy to prove it why black
has certain dynamics always
that prove that i my my experience at
least
shows uh that you know black has good
chances to
equalize and not only inquires but also
fight for the initiative in the future
so uh there again here there are lots of
possibilities for why there's
possibility again to play with knight g5
also there are possibilities like knight
e1 knight h4 right now makes
also is possible makes a little bit less
if 91 is uh alternative
because 91 is closer to center and
finally some call move like b3 is also
possible
however one of the most important things
i would like to point out is
that what happens after rookie one after
rookie one black's main
move is always 94. and the idea is to
trade the wolves knights
and try to bring this bishop to e4 and
then simplify the position
and most importantly control this e4
pawn push so uh
let's discuss after after b3 and here
again same idea knight d4
bishop b2 and now as i said takes take
now bishop b4 this is exactly what black
should do here
and right now black has number of ideas
one of the ideas is to play knight d7
and the knight f6 other possibilities
play
simply for d5 another possibility is to
maybe prepare c5 and 96 at some point
um or maybe prepare e5 breakthrough at
some point as well
it could be possible however the the
last one with the
five is much less common the most
popular is let's say 97 knight f6
maybe through d5 uh this i would
probably expect here the most
uh as the knights already traded
usually uh in kings union we always
suffer from
lack of space advan lack of space here
because knight is already traded it
means
that we have more space for our pieces
so
it should be it shouldn't be
dangerous you know the fact the fact
that the white has a little bit more
space right now
because brunei is already traded so um
i want to discuss in particular move
knight g5 because i felt like
it's the most should be at least the
most dangerous we know if 9g5 then e4
challenging this bishop from f5 building
very strong center very quickly
seems very logical and here the modern
theories are just move e5 and i really
like it
idea of e5 is that
okay right now white has essentially two
moves either takes e5 or d5
if d5 uh white can sorry black can play
with
a5 and the idea is to play through
the play play from like like knight a6
at some point after
first taking on d5 and you know
maybe if this e4 happens then we can
bring our bishop back to d7 and support
b5 so essentially we're explaining on
the king side sorry queen side
for example e4 bishop g4 queen b3
if f3 we simply go back to d7 as i was
saying
knight on g5 we can see it's kind of not
great
and we can we can play the c takes d5 in
the future knight d6 b5 and stuff like
that this could be one of
our ideas if queen b3
uh again now we can just ignore spawn on
b7 i6 queen b7 would be really really
dangerous to take such pawn
a black would have at least somewhere
perpetual
uh but probably black is risking that
white directly the screen will be simply
trapped for example if queen takes b7
i'll play knight c5 queen takes c6 and
right now the move i would
play is probably rk6 because he's the
queen
the queen goes here we can simply move
back our bishop and the queen has
nowhere actually to go already
so this is that's why white cannot take
this
pawn b7 episode bishop e3 but then we
can take take and again bishop d7
considering that uh the fact that again
knight ninja g5 is a little bit awkward
and gives black additional
10 pieces so right now knight g4 could
be a threat
and uh if knight goes back there are
ideas of b5 as well
so maybe queen also by preparing it with
queen b8
so if and if we've now queen xb7 knight
b4
this queen is a little bit also like off
on b7
while black will should have always some
compensation considering like moves like
knight c2 knight g4 or rook b8
there should be always plenty of counter
play for black
and i do not think that white has any
advantage here probably even because
black has great game here
so in my game that happened like some
time ago was d takes e5
it takes e5 queen b3 and i think that
after queen seven we simply have great
already positioned uh as black uh
rook d1 and right now even though i made
a mistake because i proved h6
is a mistake unfortunately it was a
blitz game it was titled tuesday
but anyway knight bd7 is this very
simple move
uh the it prepares h6 in the future
so uh idea is also knight c5
black has simply great great position
and i played unfortunately h6 which
uh i had similar idea i want to simply
take and temporary knight a6
and prepare f5 e4 knight c5 but
unfortunately because of bishop e3
the scientist is not going really
getting to c5 square and i think white
should be
somewhat better and also the problem is
that if f5
the c5 can follow and you know bishop
let's say you like goku h7 bishop d3
knight on a6 could be a problem
sometimes
still position is pretty unclear but
white can engineer in general
should be in general somewhat better
here
um in the game having bishop g2 but
here i solve quickly my problems i
brought mine to e6 f5 e4 follows
i think only black can be better here
objectively so
uh in the game follow like something
like this
we traded even the rooks and then the
bishops and
in this position only if anyone could be
better it'll be only black because
knight and queen co are you know usually
cooperate much better than queen and
bishop and also i have access to squares
like c5 for instance
i control the d file and i have simply
more space right now because my point is
already on e4
so that's a typical plan right right now
from from black
and uh so it means that this idea of
details if i isn't really also dangerous
so uh yeah like
finally let's discuss move knight e1
here after 91
like this position 91 also preparing e4
and for uh mainly long long time i
thought that bishop b6 should be played
here
and the idea is that simply after b3 d5
could be you know
sort of like try to expose knight only
one which is very passive
however the modern fear is also possible
not saying it's impossible but
modern theory is such as e5 and after e5
again same thing happens after after
knight g5 not only one is not the great
there's not a great piece
we immediately challenge the center
after d5 we can play cd cd and now a5
and this is what fabian carbon fabian
carolina lately played
in some some games and
again the idea is the design only one
sort of like
is not great and we want to play as
black
knight a6 bishop d7 and finally b5 there
have been some
the theoretical developments in this
position
i think personally that black has a
pretty good game even though
white maybe objectively sells somewhat
better black has easier game i would say
so i do not think that black
i i mean i think that black has you know
pretty good chances here
so coming back to d4 d6
this is what happens when uh white plays
move knight f3
and the f6 right we play
i suggest playing through bishop f5 to
not in
order not to allow let's say c4 in order
not to allow
to build very strong center with e4 and
this is let's say one one one line
one thing that the white one white can
do however there is
we have to remember also there is c4
possible right
so uh what happens after c4 right now if
you play
like you know you know i've seen bishop
f5 uh white knight is not on the free
anymore
right so if let's say this this this
would be pretty
suspicious i have a feeling because the
design is on f3 so let's say f3
we can build very quickly damage system
uh with
several extra 10ps for for white which
makes pretty much absolutely no sense
uh for for black to go for something
like this therefore
in this position i suggest going uh go
to
just play move e5 and this is the
drawback
of c4 that this e5 right now uh
move challenge in the center is possible
so what to do here is white uh there are
several possibilities
uh first thing uh it is possible to
enter the end game detects e5 detects e5
quintex d8 king takes d8
for example this this this this this
position right
so do we have to be worried about her
with black about this end game and
i would say not really like i think if
anything
white only black okay position is equal
i
i have to say position is equal true but
if anyone has great
let's say or more like better
perspectives here in this end game
it would be black uh for a simple reason
pawn on c4
pawn c4 is misplaced you'll be better if
this pawn actually on c2
because but unfortunately pawns do not
move backwards right
so uh the point is that y pawns on c4
gives some sort of maybe edge for white
in the search end game is that
black has access to let's say right now
or easier access
these two squares like c5 or in general
dark squares on the
um the queen side
and this king on the a doesn't matter is
with that kind of castle
like this black king can also all only
plays like
uh like c6 k7 and skin will be totally
safe
also bishop b697 is also a legit
approach here
as black and uh there is no way to
exploit this king king on the eighth
which kind of castle
because black king will certainly be
safe on either
queen side or back on the king's side as
an end
in the king's position uh that i mean
the fact that the king cannot castle
doesn't quite matter in my opinion
and uh so yeah here about this end game
i wouldn't
really worry as black and indeed i i had
i got to play one game is this such a
game and i managed to win the game
uh i uh i will not show this game
because it was very long
but i didn't have any problems out of
the opening and
indeed in the end i got a pre
like my mouth to move after moving like
number 20 or something i
had already great uh
in great position with good winning
chances
um but okay it just i'm well i'm just
trying to
say that this end game is not really
dangerous for black and
it potentially can become even even
better for black
so the taxi f5 i wouldn't i wouldn't
worry about
so there's three other possibilities
there is move knight f3 there's move
knight c3 and there is move d5
also there are other moves like e3 but
you know they are kind of passive
uh also e4 is possible but is also not
the most common move here uh usually
white tries to improve the center or
like string from the center by playing
knight f3
or knight c3 or
close up the center by playing d5 so
let's see what happens after
d5 at first uh d5
has this drawback that um it
immediately shows what's happening uh
you know or like it shows kind of like
closes the center and defines the pawn
structure in the center
with the structure which is with such
structure which is already defined
black has number of possibilities um
to how to put pieces there is
possibility to
delay again castle there is possibility
to
somehow trade dark square bishops
because we have to acknowledge that
bishop on the face and
it's right now not great if bishop was
on c5 would be of course very good
bishop but on f8
is kind of attacking his own pawns which
is not ideal
however if we can let's say bring this
bishop let's say bishop essential g5
with one idea
another idea would be to play g6 bishop
h6 also
try this bishop so it's all possible
because this knight from j didn't
develop yet
and also
another thing is that black can quickly
start playing with f5 is also
possibility
another possibility is at first black
can start
controlling the c5 square so in general
what i played i think
two of my games is i played immediately
a5 not declaring
yet what i'm doing with my pieces on the
king side but at first making sure that
i
control the queen side so not 93 knight
a6
and i'm not sure which path i'm gonna
take
on the queen side sir king side because
it depends also on what white is doing
for example if e4 i think that pretty
good tries
pretty good movies to play g6 because i
combine
both idea of bishop h6 and also trying
to play for f5
so uh there is
[Music]
of course huge choice i don't want to go
into deals in particular lines but i
just want to show more like ideas what
black does here
so um let's say h3 which happened in one
of my
games so right now i analyzed that f5 is
actually into very interesting try
and after it takes f5 bishop to x5 g4
bishop d7
white has nice control over the e4
square but uh
black hasn't you know developed this
bishop from fade yet we can play bishop
h6 very quickly
also um you know white has white is a
little bit behind in development of
pieces
so i think that bishop g7 also if we
don't go within bishop hc we can play
bishop
g7 knight f6 and maybe trying to play
through
uh e4 also would be you know
quite quite okay so this is one
possibility second possibility is what i
chose in
this game and i like it also a lot i
played with h5
and the idea here is first of all to
stop any sort of g4 moves
from white to the expanding on the king
side and also i'm preparing move bishop
h6
and after another three bishop h6 bishop
e2
i simply took and now i play knight f6 i
could consider already playing f5 or
something but the point is it doesn't
quite run away and i
decided to at first improve my knight
and i want to play at c5 as well
so shortcuts will make sense i play
knight c5 right now up only for his hang
um my opponent played knight g5
knight on g5 is a decent knight right
now uh so i
because it supports on the pawn on e4
and
i cannot kick it out with move h6 so i
just decided to try it with knight h7
take stakes and here i think positions
just around equal
i do not see any problems here for uh
for black
one of the ideas for black is of course
to finally get to play f5
but what is the most important uh in
normal kings indian let's say positions
something uh like this is pretty much
not attainable
here we got it after move number already
12. and this is much better version of
what happens in king's indian
because black already traded dark square
bishops and territory one pair of
knights
so the fact that white has a little bit
more space
here trying to wall spawns uh i should
also point this one
as well so white has more let's say
bird control over the center more space
but it's pretty much irrelevant
because what space is about is about
pieces
and right now black black species
have lots of room and
[Music]
yeah like there is no any reason why
black should be worried here it's a
thing perfect version of
sort of king's indian um structure
so in my in my game happened f4 which
tries to immediately challenge trying to
change the center trying to make it take
advantage of my awkward rug on h7 kings
only eight but simply doesn't work so uh
what i would probably hear play as well
would be not a four
but such move are also not easy and the
knight d4 would lead to some
complications which are
uh possible but pretty much with this
one is
not really necessary even if i can build
that for for example if
even if i play with b6 takes takes queen
d2 queen f6
uh there is no any reason for black to
be worried about
without dark square bishop and
potentially playing through g5 maybe
just bishop d7 then king
seven preparing maybe f5 sometimes i
think black has
a pretty good position so but in the
game happened the f4
after four uh it takes a four we rotate
the f4 i could have won the game
actually immediately
with bishop like the h3 which is what i
kind of like i think i saw it i had to
see but by some reason i thought it
would be the same thing
if i play queen g5 also it was a rapid
game i think so
or blitz i don't remember so i just want
to play something quickly
so queen g5 played but my opponent
played queen f1 allow me final play
bishop h3 and this the game is pretty
much over
rook f3 would all be better but after
bishop black is anyway much better
because of course
queen comes to e5 control over the dark
squares is clearly in
black's favor and
black yeah black is much better here so
uh i wouldn't curious that myself too
much over not playing bishop h3 because
queen g5
also you know leads to a huge advantage
positional advantage
but after queen f1 bishop h3 the game is
just pretty much over because i just win
a pawn
also bishop takes g2 has happened this
game
follows and the yeah this is just pretty
much
over and this is how the game ended
so uh this is let's say one example of
what can happen after d5
other possibilities playing with bishop
d3 after bishop d3
uh while black can place him bishop h6
and save knight d2
take stakes knight f6 against similar
stuff right b go knight c5
we can go through h5 and g3 and c5
should be one
again h5 i just play h4 pretty much what
i'm trying to say is all of it is better
version of regular kings indian
uh if white white only plays d5 too
early
after h4 bishop d7 uh
yeah like queen d2 happened in my game i
play simply a short castle
i want to uh at some point prepare move
f5
f3 okay now knight h7 pawn h4 is a
little bit loose it kind of why can't
castle knight d1 queen f6 idea could be
uh to play uh queen g7 and then prepare
maybe f5 at some point
i played queen g7 knight d3 trying to
finally trade this knight but i played
b6
b3 and simply finally f5 this was my
idea
all the way all the way along so take
stakes
bishop takes f5 and the white cannot
take bishop takes f5
g takes the 5 knight takes h5 because
queen g6 simply loses
a piece just to show it quickly
queen g6 simply use a piece or like even
another piece and some material because
this is simply crushing
i can simply take it here and uh why
wise position is
very very bad because the king is also
very weak my king is much safer
also what i'm talking about uh queen e4
is even stronger here
queen for ashwin is the room on the spot
so white cannot do this
white cannot do this um
white has to play bishop e4 but after
bishop b4 take stakes and rook f4
i challenge knight from e4 somehow by
playing in
either knight f6 uh but my
knife six is someone in some positions
because i have to worry about knight g5
but mostly i want i want to do here as
black is to play move g5
for instance for queen e3 rook f8 a4
[Music]
not a great move but yeah anyway black
is better
after a4 simply g5 black has great
chances to win this and i eventually we
need to win in the game
so um
therefore in this position d5 is not
really a pretty dangerous line for for
black as well
it may be tempting to play for white
because you know it just con
gains more space gains some control over
the center and so on
but it gives huge room for flexibility
in terms of
choice of setups for black and i don't
think it is really a problem here for
uh for for black here
so uh other two possibilities i consider
here as the
you know the most let's say
challenging or the most interesting uh
or something
you know worldwide should do is either
knight c3 or knight f3
and let's talk about briefly about
knight f3
after night the point of in general d6
e5
is that after knight f3 white black can
quickly play move e4
and this already creates sort of
imbalance in the position
because uh this create this gives
possibility
for black to gain uh control over the
center
and expand you know gonna pretty much
gain some space on the king side
and uh if this is uh
you know if something that is possible
black should generally
go for it of course i'm not saying
that this is you know already black is
better or something position is still
very you know dynamic and still anything
can happen
but i personally i like this position
for black
and i will just share some ideas what
can happen here
and i g5 is logical to make i mean it's
the most active move after all
uh challenge is pawn e4 now f5
we need to support this pawn and build
very strong center
uh knight c3 and bishop b7 and right now
uh
white has several uh i mean essentially
two moves possible knight h3 or
h4 after a move like h4
i would consider move like knight f6 and
again we just
we as black right now we want to simply
play very often short castle c6 and
sometimes even want to play move d5 but
we can prepare d5
in you know uh depending on what does
and
you know the point is in general to
build strong center and gain some space
which is which is following you know uh
the basic principles of you know of
playing in the opening right
so it logic is logical definitely
logical approach here
as black and there
there have been many moves one of the
moves is g3 or or e3
but after both of them while i would
play c6
and then again we want to play short
castle we want to key design from g5 out
for instance
after let's say bishop b2 makes makes
some sense let's say short castle
maybe i know b3 makes sense to develop
this bishop to b2
as black we can consider playing with
like h6
we can consider it um and then after
knight h3 maybe bishop e6 or something
however this weekend's uh you know this
king side a little bit now h594 would be
great for white right
therefore we should probably prove that
a6 is one of the typical ideas in this
opening bishop b2 and maybe knight c7
if y was to go back more that we are
wise more than more than welcome to move
the red treaty with this knight
and the left after this we can play
already bishop e6 if we want to
after 94 bishop f7 developing our bishop
and again right now we want to play with
d5
building you know very strong center
here uh as
with black pieces and d5 is possible
true
as well but it also is not
right like you know really dangerous i
guess
because we can build like a 97 id5
or we can play maybe uh even c5
if we want to there's no need to play c5
i'll probably play just 97 if h5 should
be 95 or bishop f6
both moves are interesting position is
very complicated
and both sides definitely have his own
chances
i wouldn't you know say that white or
black is better positions pretty unclear
but
as black uh you know if you want to
avoid let's say
mainstream theory let's say names or
indian or mainstream
you know kingzine or grundfault like if
we can get such
something playable like this definitely
is the opening success
so um other possibilities to play g3 and
let's say after c6 knight h396 similar
stuff
happens knight c7 short castle
position is pretty much unbalanced again
bishop e6 bishop
f7 could be an idea uh aiming get to
play d5 in the future
personally i i like splax chances so
knight f3 allows to build this strong
center with e4
so therefore i think that black is has
you know decent uh
decent position here uh one more thing i
wanted to point out
after white doesn't play h4 with white
play is knight h3
again knight f6 this is even probably
worse for
worst version of this uh for uh for
white because white
cannot get to f4 square but it has this
kind of like compensation in terms
in terms of the fact that kingside is
not really weakened and white wants to
play for f3
but f3 is not really a problem as long
as we can play always d5 so if so
therefore this idea i don't think is
quite
really you know dangerous for uh for
black
of course i'm not saying blackboard is
worse why can't please let's say d5 and
then play
f3 or something it's still okay but d5
also we can if i square so we'll play
and then b795
there is some there are some tradeoffs
that have to be considered and
in overall i wouldn't say that black is
worse here for instance after the castle
analyzed 97
which is a pretty rare move but it just
shows underlines the main black's main
idea here
to play d5 and the black can achieve a
plane after f3 knight b6
b3 and finally d5 and i don't see
any problems here for black for instance
if c5 knight bc and bd7 are the 479 b8
covering e6 square and this line
perfectly illustrates
black's main strategical objective which
was to create very strong center
and right now c6 d5 e4 f5 just mark them
black achieve that
so
[Music]
if black energy such can get such strong
center potentially in the future
black has better chances of you know
winning the game
or like at least gain some advantage on
good chances because strategically your
position is very sound
so yeah this will be it i think about
move knight f3
finally let's discuss move knight c3
which is
very interesting as well and yeah let's
just see what happens there
it is knight c3 it takes d4 we have to
right now
take on d4 cons taking uh taking
advantage of the fact that
white has taken the queen on d4 which uh
you know
queen d4 96 queen runs into tempest
uh and the best move according to modern
theory is to play with queen d2
and the point is uh white's in general
plan here
in this position is to play you know
there are actually two plants or
actually even three plants
uh one plan is to play simply e4 develop
quickly bishop d3 knight d2 or knight f3
and you know build sort of this um
strong center of pawns e4 and c4 this is
one
second plan would be to play b3 and
bishop b2 double displacement on this
diagonal
and then decide whether to play for g3
and
or e4 and in general
after b3 bishop b2 usually if the move
is to which white goes for his move
knight d5
uh at least the move that you know what
has to consider and then also i can
decide whether to go with g3 or e3 both
are possible and finally the setup for
white would be to
the final setup for white would be to
play through g3 and then bishop g2
and sort of you know put this bishop on
this long diagonal and
play sort of typical as the king's
indians position
with after trade on on d4 with bishop on
g2 which
on this diagonal is usually well placed
so right now black should play with
knight f6
and the thing about this position
in particular in particular about this
position is that
um black hasn't declared
yet where this bishop from efi is going
to be developed there is possibility
that this bishop may stay uh on this
diagonal
f8 a3 or e3f8 or it can be developed to
g7 by playing g6 bishop g7 but
the point is that we are not declaring
what we're gonna do
as black yet and white has to figure out
and has
some make some choice and it is not
entirely easy to
show or like you know first of all i
think black is doing well here
but also it's not easy to choose for the
for the setup for
uh for white for example if white plays
move like
which to start with which one should i
start with
let's start with e4 let's say if e4
we we cannot forget that you know the
screen on d2 is a little bit
odd and usually in such positions
white schneider should be on d4 queen on
d1 right so we
get we got some time here for uh for
some dynamics
uh for some dynamic play with black so
here i would suggest going for sort of
gcses and bishop design is let's say
king's indian setup
let's say bishop d3 alternative would be
let's say to play b3
after bishop g7 bishop b2 this bishop
and b2
is aiming to neutralize bishop on g7
and here we go short castle
the point uh i mean the idea right now
for black is to
because we have to see that blacks has
advantage in development of pieces right
and with such advantage black has to
play very dynamically because if only
white manages to develop
all the pieces strategically what would
be better because of the
you know more space more better control
over the center
white uh black i mean black pieces will
run out of you know
will will sort of be experiencing lack
of space
so having said that black has to play
very dynamic choice right now
so uh after bishop d3 you know this move
makes a lot of sense because tries to
you know develop this knight to
e2 let's say and then short castle
then maybe knight d5 try to you know get
let's say some you know nice positional
advantage
and this is a valid approach as well for
white but why black
can react by playing with a6 and this is
the dynamics i'm talking about
we black i'm sorry white no it's not in
time to
quickly develop those pieces
without blackhead getting a counterplay
afternoon g2 knight d5
short castle seemingly white black shift
sorry why that shift everything you know
great and x95 is coming y has great uh
strategic advantage
however black can play already move b5
and this is
where this dynamic factor comes into
play black thanks to the dynamic play
black
has really really good chances to play
this even for a win so suddenly
what's the point and this idea of a6b5
is very common in this type of positions
especially
where uh you know white has sort of like
so delayed development of the king side
and still has to catch up on
black will have very often time for such
activity
so similarly we're just giving the point
right but indeed it's an interesting
pawn sacrifice
he stays b5 knight takes d3 point takes
d3 a takes b5
if knight takes b5 simply c6 and
we have pair of bishops and thanks to
bishop on c8 still we can
and open this diagonal we can bring this
bishop to a6
where it will be doing lots of harm to
uh
to white knight c3 should be played
because of knight c3
bishop a6 would actually win a piece
because those knights are pretty loose
and
you know white simply loses the piece
just to show for example if queen let's
say d1
let's say take take take and e5 is made
by queen e6 and finally queen on e2
is not uh protected so
black uh white cannot take on f6
so uh if knight bc free then we should
sorry irrigate first
and the idea is at some point probably
to play bishop basics
and d5 and you know challenge you know
white center essentially i think black
has great compensation here for the
sacrifice pawn for example queen c2
knight takes e4 knight is e4 bishop
takes b2 queen takes b2 rook to z4 black
and already win the pawn back
and i'm not saying black is better but
definitely not worse
for instance knight c3 queen f6 rook d1
d5 like
no any problems here for for black and
bishop
may prove because potion is quite open
may in the future of course
very hypothetical may prove stronger
than the knight
as i say it's hypothetical may doesn't
have to but just still around equal but
probably i'll choose here to if i have
to choose sides i'll probably choose
black in this position nonetheless
position is pretty equal
all right so after short castle there's
bishop d3
which is a movie which we just discussed
alternative would be let's say to play
f3
and after f f3 this move again
stabilizes the center because pawn e4
could be always some sort of attack of
object of an attack and right now we
can't
we look for counterplay in different way
we play a5
and the idea is to quickly change the
queen side
with muppon uh with the move a4 for
instance right now bishop d3
knight d5 and even though we don't have
a6 b5 right now we can play
through a4
this is one let's say idea other
possibility in this particular
instance would be bishop h6 which you
know
you guys can see that with this king
only one white king only one
there is lots of activity for black lots
of dynamic uh
possibilities for for black to you know
use
and you know disrupt easy development
for
and you know playing for the space
advantage
i especially want to show that what
happens after a4 because this is very
interesting
after knight takes a4 rook takes a4 pawn
takes
knight takes e4 all score of tactics
like this already
works knight pawn takes e4 net xd3 takes
takes ruby one bishop e5
and and we got this position where
white has just you know uh extra
exchange but black has
huge compensation in the form of two uh
two bishops
pair of bishops and uh great control
over the
e5 square and you know really powerful
bishop on e5
i don't think black objectively from
practical it's a point of view takes any
risk here
i think black is just doing great here
maybe black is not better but definitely
not worse
great compensation so this idea of
e4 and runs into g6 and suddenly
we can see that while simply not quite
in time to develop
um you know actually i didn't
i didn't say about bishop d3 but after
b3
while simply by not in time to quickly
develop the pieces
and you know finish the development
because black always has some dynamics
um so after e4
g6 there's bishop d3 also move and here
we can play bishop g7 and again we can
go for similar stuff
a6 and ideas to play b5 at some point
and the the problem is that queen on d2
disturbs his bishop from c1
and it's not easy to actually you know
play rhino queen d1 because queen d1
okay knight d5
and okay i win the pair of bishops i
would definitely not have any problems
here
with with black so if b3 at least we're
just trying to justify screen on d2
but again we can play b5 and now knight
b4 also 95 could be possible i guess
but uh knight you know before probably
even stronger
uh black has similar idea we aim for
dynamics and the
black internal generation do quite well
here
so um having said that let's go back to
position after queen 2 and knight f6
in this position there are also two
other possibilities for white
and the one is to play b3 one is to play
g3
i want to talk at first about quickly
about b3 after b3
uh black should play a5 again if we play
passively like you know bishop e7
shortcuts or something
black why why we able to you know
develop you know nicely all the pieces
and get have an advantage if we play
very
dynamic chats with a5 we maybe want to
play a4
after bishop b2 a4 suddenly it could be
not so easy
and the thing is that knight x a4 may
run into moves like d5 and suddenly we
are not developing this bishop from
f8 to g7 but we go this bishop to b4 and
considering this lack of development of
the king side
we are sacrificing the pawn true but we
are getting huge
let's say act an activity and a great
play in the center
this could be this could and this could
end game on this
and the game on this bishop before
diagonal very quickly
uh this is very dangerous uh for for
example like let's say
the line i can see right now i didn't
analyze it too deeply but i can see and
i will consider is something like this
we should be 4 and 94 and
[Music]
black wins so this is very very
dangerous on this diagonal and
considering how quickly black pieces can
join the game and
an attack so uh white cannot i think
take this pawn on a4 but if so it plays
let's say rook d1
it takes b3 it takes b3 we can already
see that uh
arrogant a is perfectly placed whenever
this knight goes from d5 we can at least
consider
this considers moves like rook a2 or
something not saying this
would be great but at least we can we
have active rook and we can take
advantage of that
so right now i analyze move g6 finally
switching back to
regular development because everything
is controlled but let's say
after 95 bishop g7
i don't see any problems here for black
uh
thanks you know very active pieces very
quick development
i think that black is doing simply great
for instance after queen g5
a blackhead has a choice to play for
simple equality with knight takes d5
and in such and go for end game which is
around equal
i don't see any problems for black or
playing something more ambitious like
knight h5
after uh quintex 18 takes d8 this is
actually just much better because rook
e3 is uh coming
and black has huge the
advantage in development of pieces
so if and if queen e3 we should be six
this
you know also leaves black with some
good with great chances because black is
simply better
than you know already castle black's
king is saved white is still in the
center
and the f5 is coming maybe bishop takes
d5 maybe then queen f6
a bunch of possibilities for uh for
black
and it is why has to be really careful
here
so this idea of
b3 is not particularly dangerous in my
opinion
because because of this a5 a4 this is
very important to remember is if b
freedom a5a4 immediately puts pressure
on the queen side
and if knight takes a4 ideas of d5
always
are there right so this is very very
important thing to
know and remember so finally let's
discuss what happens after g3 and
g3 i think is uh uh okay it's just
possible because but right now we go
bishop e6 we do not develop g6 bishop g7
because uh we can at first attack spawn
on c4 which is
you know we can attack it right so we
should be six and right now in my game
uh which again against aditya mittal
which was played in title tuesday white
played
e3 my opponent played d3 which is
actually a huge mistake
probably just losing mistake
white should have played move knight d5
and here black has
several possibilities one possibility is
to play knight e5 and second possibility
is to play g6
but you know considering that only
already on d5
let's say bishop g2 bishop g7 h3 castle
knight f4
uh bishop d7 you know it's not
ideal setup for uh for white this is
with nine on f4
because uh you know knight f3 it's kind
of
uh leaving this knight i mean
it's not like it's a bad move but uh you
know it's
it doesn't support the 95 so well so we
can kill pond if i could be object of
some attack in the future
uh also maybe even immediately i would
i'll probably consider maybe
taking this immediately and attacking
spawn because i know how to defend this
actually
because if knight goes to um d4 we can
just probably take it
and ig one of course not that is not not
a good move
now h4 and g5 are also a little bit off
so it could be possible something like
this but
even if 90 bishop plays d5 is possible
just shortcut is totally fine and the
idea of knight e4 knight c5
is also decent also maybe knight e5
was black at some point probably later
even just you know after let's say after
this rook e8 it's not clear how white
develops the bishop from c1
and i don't see any problems here for
black but i think black has a really
good game
also possible is to play an id5 in order
to go into too many details
just i would just show what is the line
here b c6
knight f6 the queen of c bishop b2 and
considering this threat of f4
we simply have to prevent it by playing
with g5 this is which is a very
interesting novelty actually
and the black plays bishop g7 next and
put some pressure on this bishop on the
design
on this bishop on b2 for example this
this rogue d1 knight d3 is already
great for black injury position is good
for black but
here while can black and win pair of
bishops
so i think black is simply doing great
here so
talking finally about this let's get to
my game with e3
and here is the main sort of idea of
this line
to attach pawn on c4 and right now go
through d5
because white is simply not in time to
bring this bishop to g2
and uh you know in this particular line
so right
you know in order to stop d5 y has to
play move d5 knight d5 right
but because e3 runs into d5 and suddenly
white is in huge trouble because black
has perfect development
and queen ontario is very awkward bishop
before idea is coming
it's very dangerous suddenly and
actually the game lasted only 15 moves
so i'll just quickly show it
stay d5 knight xd5 knight g2 now
i'd say play knight b4 ideas 93
so knight f4 i decided to take we should
be to the c2
blue wins the rook so king d2 has to be
played and now i think i play restaurant
bishop g4
uh preventing his king from joining it
from going to
this squares and i want to go along
castle as well
knight b5 long castle king c3 and simply
g5 and
the game is pretty much over bishop g7
is coming
i4 is hanging and the game happened this
this
and after rook d3 my opponent resigned
because of king
c4 is made by knight a5 checkmate or
knight v5 checkmate right
um so
yeah this is how the game ended after
the freemap and resigned
um in general this game shows
that the danger that you know is around
uh
you know white in this line especially
when it's not
when while player white is not really
familiar with this with this stuff
so yeah okay this would be in general
all for
for this lesson about this opening i
think it's a very interesting
line for black to play with correctly
white objectively should be somehow in
some lines better
but nonetheless black has
really good counter chances and
i wouldn't say that white you know that
black is suffering there
may be objectively black studies while
slightly better but black has its own
chances too
and especially if you want to avoid
theory after let's say you know d4 let's
avoid let's say makings india or
grundfold or
some nimzo india or slav or anything and
you just want to play
get something playable quickly and your
and you know your opponent doesn't play
one e4 but only one d4
d4 d6 could be a good good try and good
opening
to achieve that so yeah that's all from
me for
for now and i'll be back soon with the
next lesson which will be games of the
[Music]
week
you